Muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos un vídeo
sobre las elecciones mexicanas. Hablamos de
las elecciones más importantes de la historia
de México, que a su vez es el país más
grande del mundo hispanoparlante ¿Y por qué
son tan importantes? Pues porque son las primeras
donde México podría estar diciéndole adiós
al bipartdismo.
Pero esperad un momento porque hablar de bipartidismo en México es mucho decir.
Para que os hagáis una idea, este país ha tenido
al mismo partido en el gobierno durante 70
años. Tal cual como lo oís. Desde el año
1930 hasta el año 2000, todos los inquilinos
del palacio presidencial, también conocido
como LA RESIDENCIA DE LOS PINOS, venían del
PARTIDO REVOLUCIONARIO INSTITUCIONAL ¿Cómo
se puede ser revolucionario e institucional
al mismo tiempo? ¡No lo sé! Pero ese es
el nombre que le dieron a este partido, aunque
se le conoce mejor por sus siglas, el PRI.
El PRI es algo así como el gran partido del
centro-izquierda mexicano. Y sí, ya sé que
muchos mexicanos no estaréis de acuerdo si
digo que el PRI es de centro-izquierda pero
pensad que tengo que hacer un resumen para
que lo entiendan todos los que vean este vídeo
desde otros países. Lo cierto es que el PRI
estuvo gobernando México por 70 años. Después
del año 2000, tuvimos 12 años de gobiernos
del Partido Acción Nacional, también conocido
como el PAN, que es el partido de centro-derecha.
Después, en el año 2012, es cuando el PRI
volvió al poder de la mano de Enrique Peña Nieto
también conocido como el presidente
peor valorado de la historia de México.
Pues bien, es ahora, en 2018, cuando los
Estados Unidos Mexicanos afrontarán el
1 de julio unas elecciones decisivas ¿Y quién es el
candidato con más posibilidades? Pues ni
el del PRI ni el del PAN. El posible nuevo
presidente es este señor que veis aquí que
se llama Andrés Manuel López Obrador.
Empresarios, preocupados por propuestas de
AMLO en materia económica
Esta sería la tercera vez que se presenta
a las elecciones. Y parece que va a ser la
definitiva. López Obrador o, como se le conoce
en México, AMLO, se presente con propuestas
propuestas que… están generando bastante
¿Cómo decirlo? ¡Pánico! Entre los inversores
internacionales. Algunos incluso dicen que
México podría ser la nueva Venezuela.
Sin embargo, el mayor enemigo de AMLO en estos
momentos no es otro que él mismo. Sus declaraciones
generan miedo entre los votantes más moderados,
que podrían lanzarse en masa a votar a alguno
de los otros dos candidatos.
Así que, llegados
a este punto, la pregunta es ¿Por qué AMLO
puede ganar las elecciones? ¿Cuáles son
sus propuestas? ¿Hay razones para tenerle
miedo? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
TÍTULO: LA GRAN DECEPCIÓN MEXICANA
A comienzos de siglo, parecía que México
se iba a comer el mundo.
Con multitud de recursos
naturales, como el petróleo o la plata por
citar algunos, y siendo una de las economías
emergentes mejor valoradas por los inversores,
en 2010 el país creció un 5,5%. Sin embargo,
al igual que ha ocurrido con otras grandes
promesas como Brasil o Sudáfrica, las grandes
esperanzas Mexicanas se terminaron de desinflar
en 2016.
PIB en dólares de México, en su nivel más
bajo desde 2010
Todo esto es sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta
que México tiene todas las posibilidades
para triunfar. Tienen petróleo, un buen clima
para la agricultura y toda clase de recursos
naturales. Además, hacen frontera con la
mayor mercado del mundo: ESTADOS UNIDOS.
De hecho, si lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik,
ya sabéis que México tiene un tratado de
libre comercio con Estados Unidos, el TLCAN.
De hecho, el 80% de las exportaciones mexicanas
se dirigen a su vecino del Norte.
Pese a todo esto, México sigue siendo un
país de renta media, con sueldos bajos y
con un nivel de vida muy por debajo del de
Estados Unidos o Canadá. Y os preguntaréis
¿Por qué? Pues veréis, después de 70 años
de endogamia del PRI, corrupción y narcotráfico,
México vivía con unas instituciones prácticamente
medievales.
Para los que estéis pensando, “Fonseca,
creo que estás exagerando un poco” ¿Verdad?
Pues… juzgad por vosotros mismos. Hasta
el año 2016, en su sistema judicial no existía
la presunción de inocencia y que ni siquiera
había que reunir pruebas para decretar una
culpabilidad. En muchos casos, bastaba con
una confesión, obtenida con tortura policial,
para meter a alguien en la cárcel. Para que
os hagáis una idea, los expertos llamaban
a este sistema judicial el “modelo inquisitorial”.
Tal cual como lo oís.
A esto hay que sumarle el narcotráfico, que
ya se ha llevado por delante a más de 200.000
personas en sólo 11 años. Para que os hagáis
una idea, en algunas zonas de México, los
narcos tienen más poder que el propio estado.
A esto, en ciencia política, lo llamamos
una situación de “estado fallido”. Y
es lo que tienen en muchas zonas de África…
y en muchas zonas de México.
En otras palabras, que México necesitaba
y necesita algo más que reformas. Necesita
dar un giro de 180º.
¿Y quién era la persona indicada para hacer
este trabajo? Pues nada más y nada menos
que el Enrique Peña Nieto, que llegó al
gobierno en el año 2012. ¿El problema? Que
todavía es muy pronto para que los mexicanos
noten mejoras en su nivel de vida. Es más,
las desigualdades sociales no hacen más
que crecer.
A eso hay que sumarle que el mayor problema
de Peña Nieto es… el mismo Peña Nieto.
Pocas personas han trabajado más duramente
por hundir su propia credibilidad. Básicamente,
Peña Nieto lo tiene todo: casos de corrupción
que afectan a su propia persona, una supuesta
tesis doctoral falsa y tráfico de influencias
de todo tipo. Por si esto fuera poco, cuando
Donald Trump estaba en campaña electoral,
insultando a los mexicanos todos los días,
al Presidente de México no se le ocurrió
nada mejor que invitarle para un debate, como
si ya hubiera ganado las elecciones ¿Y qué
me decís de la lucha contra el narcotráfico?
Después de haber encerrado al Chapo Guzmán,
que sería algo así como el Pablo Escobar
mexicano, va y se le escapa de la cárcel
a través de un túnel al que sólo le faltaba
aire acondicionado. Vamos, que a nadie deberían
sorprenderle noticias como esta.
Encuesta en México: Peña Nieto es el presidente
peor evaluado
En definitiva, el Gobierno de Peña Nieto
ha representado para los mexicanos el de la
decepción definitiva con los políticos.
Ante este panorama, con el PRI lejos de ser
un partido en el que confiar y el PAN ofreciendo
una alternativa poco atractiva, los mexicanos
han perdido sus esperanzas en los partidos
tradicionales. Es el momento de AMLO.
TÍTULO: ¿PERO QUIÉN ES AMLO?
Hubo un tiempo en el que Andrés Manuel López
Obrador militó en el PRI. En los años 80
se afilió al partido dominante de México
y durante 11 años ocupó todo tipo de cargos
segundarios. Por aquellos años, el Partido
era más Institucional que Revolucionario.
Y por eso, AMLO se marchó y se montó su
propio partido. El Partido de la Revolución
Democrática. El auténtico faro de la izquierda
mexicana.
Durante los años 90, AMLO intentó ganar
las elecciones a Gobernador de Tabasco. Pero
conseguir derrotar al PRI parecía una misión
imposible. Hasta el año 2000: el año de
la gran debacle del PRI. En ese momento, los
conservadores del PAN llegan al gobierno.
Y AMLO llega a ser alcalde de la Ciudad de
México.
Ser el alcalde de la ciudad más grande de
todo Latino América es el mejor escaparate
mediático que puede tener un político. Y
esto fue su trampolín a la presidencia.
En el año 2006, AMLO se presentó a las elecciones
presidenciales y apenas se quedó a 250.000
votos de la presidencia.
¿Y qué hizo después de “casi” ganar
unas elecciones? Pues realizar acusaciones
de fraude electoral, organizar múltiples
protestas callejeras y ser proclamado por
los suyos como el presidente
Todo esto puede ser un anticipo de lo que
puede pasar si las urnas vuelven a alejarle
de Los Pinos.
Pues bien, ahora que conocemos la trayectoria
del personaje, vamos a centrarnos en su programa.
Básicamente, AMLO propone dar marcha atrás
en, prácticamente, todas las reformas que
aprobó Enrique Peña Nieto. En otras palabras,
una vuelta al pasado.
¿Queréis ejemplos? Pues aquí tenemos la
reforma energética. Hasta hace un par de
años, todo el petróleo mexicano dependía
de la empresa estatal; PEMEX, que tenía unas
perdidas enormes y toda clase de corruptelas.
Peña Nieto quitó el monopolio de PEMEX y
permitió que pudieran invertir en el país
las empresas extranjeras. Pues bien, AMLO
quiere volver a la situación anterior. Y
lo mismo pasa con la reforma educativa. Como
veíamos en este otro vídeo, Peña Nieto
quitó el poder a los sindicatos de profesores.
Y otra vez, AMLO propone devolvérselo.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué propone para acabar
con el narcotráfico? Hablamos de uno de los
peores problemas de México ¿Verdad? Pues…
atentos porque esta es buena.
AMLO no sólo quiera acabar con la guerra
contra el narco, sino que, además, no descarta
la opción de decretar una amnistía. De hecho,
en campaña ha llegado a pronunciar frases
como esta:
Pero, sin duda alguna, lo más sorprendente
de AMLO son sus recetas mágicas. Por ejemplo
¿Cómo podemos acabar con la corrupción?
¡Muy sencillo! Para AMLO, es tan fácil como
redactar lo que el llama una “CONSTITUCIÓN
MORAL”. Eso y quitarles la inmunidad a los
diputados del parlamento. Por cierto que esto
de relacionar la corrupción con el hecho
de que los diputados tengan inmunidad jurídica
me hace mucha gracia porque lo he escuchado
ya en varias campañas electorales. Y os voy
a contar un secreto, tanto en Dinamarca como
en Nueva Zelanda, que son los países menos
corruptos del planeta, los diputados tienen
inmunidad.
Pero de eso hablaremos en otro vídeo. Lo
cierto es AMLO tiene soluciones rápidas y
sencillas para todo ¿Qué hay paro juvenil?
¡Muy fácil! El Gobierno dará trabajos para
los jóvenes ¿Qué la gasolina es cara? ¡No
hay problema! El gobierno construirá nuevas
plantas de refinado.
En otras palabras, que AMLO, y su movimiento
político que se llama el MORENA, genera tanta
simpatía en una mitad de México como pesadillas
en la otra.
elecciones. Pero… ¿Hasta qué punto está
realmente dispuesto a llevarlo a cabo? ¿Y
si todo fueran palabras “bonitas” para
ganar las elecciones? Ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver.
TÍTULO: ¿POPULAR O POPULISTA?
Quedaos con este nombre: Alfonso Romo. Se
trata de un empresario de Monterrey al que
ha contratado AMLO para ser el portavoz de
campaña ¿Y cuál es su misión? Pues, simple
y llanamente, moderar el discurso de AMLO.
Con todos los sondeos y encuestas de intención
de voto a su favor, AMLO necesita acercarse
al centro político. Y para eso, Alfonso Romo
es la persona ideal. No sólo viene del mundo
de la empresa, lo que contrasta con el perfil
tan de izquierdas de AMLO. Es que, además,
Romo ha apoyado siempre a los candidatos conservadores
del PAN. Y no es el único. En realidad, dentro
del equipo de campaña de MORENA podemos encontrar
toda clase de perfiles bastante más moderados
que su líder. Y su presencia ya se está
notando.
¿Recordáis que os decía que AMLO proponía
acabar con la reforma energética? Pues ahora
Alfonso Romo asegura que lo que se hará es
una revisión de los contratos otorgados a
las compañías extranjeras, pero matizando
que, bueno, a ver, en general, las cosas se
han hecho bastante bien… o algo así. Vamos,
que ni sí, ni no, ni todo lo contrario…
AMLO ya cambió de opinión y dice sí a la
apertura energética, según Alfonso Romo
Mientras tanto, no parece que haya ningún
candidato capaz de aglutinar todos la oposición
que podría haber con AMLO. Eso significa,
que este hombre tiene posibilidades más que
plausibles para llegar al gobierno.
Así
que ahora la pregunta es ¿Creéis que
AMLO llevará a cabo las propuestas iniciales
de su programa? ¿O tal vez sus asesores van
a poder moderar su discurso? ¿Es AMLO un
riesgo para México… o es difícil hacerlo
peor que sus predecesores?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
abrazo y hasta pronto.